[Applaudissements]
comment on fait pour s'aimer alors cessé
mais c'est mes essais mais ça tombe bien
parce qu'en langue des signes ne peut
pas faire l'un sans l'autre on m'a
demandé mais comment on fait cesser mais
c'est s'est blessé mais en fait c'est
les trois à la fois en langue des signes
mais je crois que dans la vraie vie
c'est pareil et puis au delà
moi je crois que pour réussir aller au
delà pour que cette eau de la tienne la
route
longtemps nous emmène à chaque fois un
peu plus loin il faut oser traverser
pourquoi je vous parle de ça aujourd'hui
parce que ça fait quarante trois ans de
recherche appliquée d'un voyage
certainement le plus intéressant et
utile que j'ai jamais fait et qui
m'amène aujourd'hui vous dire que le
bien le plus précieux que j'ai c'est
justement mon aptitude à aimer et la
bonne nouvelle c'est que cette aptitude
ça s'apprend il ya pas ceux qui naissent
avec et ceux qui descendent et que ma
mémé c'est comme le marketing mais mais
mais on peut le faire bien et on peut le
faire mal et ça peut même faire mal
alors apprendre à tisser des relations
de qualité c'est de l'or en barre
on n'y croit pas encore assez puissant
et s'il y avait une chose à cultiver
c'est celle ci quand j'avais 14 ans j'ai
reçu de son auteur cet autocollant il
m'a jamais quitté d'ailleurs je les
retrouvais un avant de venir ici
déclaration des droits à l'amour
quand j'ai lu ça d'abord je me suis dis
ouah le rêve c'est un jour j'arrive à
faire ça et du coup je me suis dit si
quelqu'un l'a écrit c'est que c'est
possible
donc je décide d'y croire je me suis dit
aussi je décide d'y avoir droit
même moi qui avait été un peu abîmée
pour bien savoir aimer ou blessés mais
qu un peu beaucoup
et puis troisième chose que je me suis
dit je veux comprendre comment on fait
un arrêt depuis j'ai jamais arrêté de
chercher alors pas seulement entre un
homme une femme entre deux femmes entre
deux hommes mais avec tous les humains
en général comment on fait ça je crois
que quand on réussit ça qu'on soit dans
le marketing dans une association ou
ailleurs ont des potes et puis
aujourd'hui la cabane à gratter la
cabane à gratter une petite association
de rue dans mon quartier j'ai rencontré
pour la première fois il ya quelques
années maintenant installé sur le
trottoir une petite cahute en bois
peinte maison de toutes les couleurs
quand je les ai rencontrés pour la
première fois elle était tenue par
gervais un grand black un peu costaud
comme ça à l'air avec un coeur d'or et
qui savait très bien s'y prendre pour
faire de la place à chacun qu'il soit
d'où qu'ils viennent
et ça ça a suffi à accrocher mon coeur
est moi qui ai toujours eu à coeur de
mettre de la diversité dans ma vie déjà
au moins pour la mourir moins bête parce
que la réalité est toujours complexe et
bien j'ai commencé à fréquenter la
cabane moi aussi comme ces gens isolés
du quartier
comme les personnes voilà quelques-unes
en apercevoir des racines et en
transition - de chez elle comme il peut
y en avoir dans un quartier de la gare
est ce que j'ai aimé à la cabane à
gratter ces deux choses la petite phrase
que vous avez lu tout à l'heure d'un
habitué de la cabane qui dit quand on
gratte pas on peut pas savoir
eh ben je trouve que c'est vrai pour
tous ne jamais se contenter des
apparences en ce qui me concerne et en
ce qui te concerne
en ce qui nous concerne toujours prendre
la peine de gratter un peu derrière
on y découvre des pépites du coup comme
ce monsieur là aussi avec des mânes
bûcherons et qui un jour de la fête de
noël à la cabane nous fabriquent des
fleurs en papier crépon comme vous en
avez jamais vus voilà gratter derrière
les apparences
et puis à la fin de cette fête de noël
et bien sans doute voilà les plus belles
fêtes de noël que je passe depuis
quelques temps maintenant et bien je
rentre chez moi dans ma maison avec mes
enfants qui vont à l'école sont au chaud
et bien c'est pas si simple d'être à
parité de passer de doses et même depuis
ma place à moi passer cette fête de noël
avec quelqu'un qui lui a une histoire à
coucher dehors on devrait avec quelqu'un
qui a plus rien avec quelqu'un qui a
personne autour de lui pour limoux et
cette capacité à être profondément
connectés d'humain à humain quelles que
soient les statuts quel que soit voilà
notre place et pouvoir être là ensemble
c'est un plaisir pro
on devrait en avoir plus souvent et
cette aptitude là encore une fois elle
se cultive alors il ya quelques passages
obligés pour ça que je parle de
traverser un suffit pas d'avoir des
bottes de sept lieues simple est la
première personne à rencontrer ces soi
et il a fallu que je traverse
ça tombe bien parce que pour se
rencontrer
on a la matière première la plus infinie
qui existent renouvelable gratuite
hyper performantes disponibles tout le
temps et chez tout le monde
tout est là et tout est juste c'est ma
sensibilité c'est votre sensibilité
réapprendre à sentir apprendre quelque
chose que je sans comprendre quelque
chose de ce que je tends et agir alors
deux idées reçues contre qui me révolte
régulièrement la première c'est qu'il y
aurait des émotions négatives
toutes les émotions sont importantes
saleh c'est comme dans le petit jeu où
quand on est petit on dit tu brûles
tueur froid dit voilà si on nous dit que
tu brûles il manque d'infos quand même
on peut chercher longtemps avant de
d'arriver au bon endroit
donc on a besoin des autres indications
bien que ce soit des traces de colère
peur de tristesse toutes ces indications
sont juste celle dont on a besoin pour
aller vers la satisfaction suffisante de
nos besoins et là et le plaisir on
appelle ça le plaisir chez les humains
mais en fait c'est de l'homéostasie
c'est tout organisme vivant est
programmé pour satisfaire suffisamment
ses besoins fondamentaux donc pas
d'émotions négatives elles sont toutes
bonnes à prendre et quant à elle prend
le tour d'une émotion qui seraient 10
triste voire violente que ce soit pour
soi même pour les autres ça n'est pas
une émotion
c'est un mécanisme de défense c'est pas
la même chose
voilà et nous mécanismes de défense on
en a tous un genre de court circuit et
ça nous vient de loin en général voilà
ça nous vient de très loin en général
donc même ça nous devons être capables
cette zone d'ombré ou de vulnérabilité
nous devons être capable de la respecter
parce que derrière il ya une fleur en
papier crépon et du coup de le regarder
avec tendresse
il n'y a que comme ça qu'elle nous
délivrera la formation dont on a besoin
pour pouvoir faire différemment et enfin
quelque chose d'utile pour réellement
alimenter la boucle la première idée
reçue d'accord première révolte tout est
bon dans l'émotion deuxième idée on peut
pas changer
alors ça moi ça me désespère j'entendais
des gens me dire à 14 ans menace on peut
pas changer
quelle bonne excuse quelle bonne excuse
pour pas bouger les lignes et les
siennes évidemment d'abord parce que la
deuxième rencontre à faire c'est toi et
moi que tu sois mon conjoint à mon
voisin mon boss dont collaborateurs la
boulangère toi et moi déjà là de la
diversité là déjà il commence à nous un
d'agacer un peu je pense que vous avez
déjà rempli comme d'une voiture avec
votre compagne ou compagnon n'a pas la
même façon
maintenant je laisse faire c'est plus
simple voilà mais justement maintenant
je laisse faire
donc la deuxième rencontre c'est entre
ses passes et du coup toi ou moi a
toutefois et tout moi et ce qui est
dingue je mesure ces derniers sam
émerveille encore quand je vois que ça
marche c'est que quand je suis tout moi
et je lâche pas ça me laisse d'ailleurs
assez tranquille à la frontière pour que
l'autre soit toutefois
et alors quand tous les deux ont réussi
ça il ya autre chose qui arrive quoi que
j'aurais jamais inventé toute seule et
qu'elle aurait jamais inventé tout seul
et c'est encore mieux que ce qu'on
aurait pu imaginer
donc bienvenue dans la vraie vie mais en
mieux
c'est un peu de la réalité augmentée
voyez la diversité assumée voilà
seulement se rencontrer comme ça c'est
du courage
donc la première chose dont vous devez
vous équiper ses votre sensibilité et la
deuxième chose c'est pas tellement le
sens de l'effort d'ailleurs je n'ai
jamais beaucoup les profs le savent ceux
qui m'ont eu en cours le savent sens de
l'effort s'est jamais mon truc par
contre j'aime bien quand ça marche
et j'aime les gens et quand je dessine
des bus quelqu'un eh ben je décide de ne
pas lâcher si facilement
et du coup je m'occupe du entre mes
tongs l'énergie à avoir le courage
d'aller au contact
je suis sûr qu ici et mois plus tard
qu'il ya une minute quand pierre partait
dans les coulisses
j'ai voulu y toucher la main pour qu'ils
me sente proche à et puis il avait
tourné le dos à ben c'était trop tard
bien quand vous avez quelque chose de
bon un compliment comme ça que vous
retenez que vous ne dites pas il manque
à l'univers cessa de perdus pour
l'univers et puis bien sûr on a tous des
choses qui nous reste en travers tension
quelque chose
voilà on ne s'est pas occupé parce que
pas le temps parce que c'est pas si
important parce que c'est pas la peine
et bien quand ça reste en travers c'est
qu'il ya encore quelque chose à faire et
puis ça pourrait bien sinon finir par se
mettre en travers de ma santé au travers
de notre relation mettre à distance
se rencontrer se rencontrer puis déjà
une fois qu'on sait faire ça de mieux en
mieux phase pratique ça se décide ça se
tisse alors on peut se rencontrer
là ça se complique y compris là tous les
liens là parce qu'il ya le lien là puis
après il ya le lien entre les personnes
tous ceux qui s'occupent des clips de
collectifs de système humain n'est ce
pas le tedx eh ben on sait que voilà il
va falloir s'occuper de chacun et
s'occuper du entre et que si on sait
bien faire ça le résultat est encore au
delà des espérances
pourquoi ça se complique un moment où on
devient un collectif parce qu'en fait on
est tous avec une question on vient au
monde avec mais quelle est ma place
déjà trouvé ma place dans la famille
même si elle est toute petite
l'appui trouver ma place même dans mon
collectif d'amis dans mon job dans mon
entreprise dans mon un saut de mal à
trouver ma place et dès que j'ai peur
pour ma place vous dès que c'est pas sûr
d'en avoir les choses se crise donc
quand on sait qu'en chacun dans un
groupe ose prendre sa place s'occupe du
entre pour que chacun puisse et la
permission réel de prendre sa place
alors il ya une espèce de truc magique
qui se passe qui est il ya de la place
pour tout le monde
c'est de cette intelligence là à la fois
émotionnel relationnel mais aussi cette
espèce de saut dans le vide ne pas avoir
de plan préétabli au départ de dire si
on mise sur ce qui hélas que chacun
prenne ses limites ses handicaps c'est
pas possible c'est voilà la
complémentarité fera forcément quelque
chose de bien et ça c'est un sacré
lâcher prise sur notre envie de
contrôler savoir à l'avancé et c'est
valable dans comment j'élabore ma
stratégie d'entreprise
comment je pilote la cabane à gratter
comment voilà faire de la place à chacun
et pour le reste laisser-faire l'univers
et bien c'est trois choses là jamais
l'intelligence artificielle pourrait le
faire un autre place savoir sais mais ça
s'apprend c'est notre bien le plus
précieux alors cultivant le
[Applaudissements]